did you see that Dahmer thing
no you didn't watch it not yet oh God
no I heard a story about a friend of
mine
grew up in the midwest a long time ago
when I was in Yeshiva was in seminary
but he went over to somebody's house and
uh he made a Dahmer joke you know
everybody got quiet you know where this
was going
what my cousin was one of the victims no
and he goes oh I gotta like no it's okay
he goes no I gotta go I can't be here
anymore I'm so sorry and he left
Seminary no he told he was in seminary
told me the story
um it was just so uncomfortable
[Music]
um
but you know wrong audience for sure but
it's probably still a good joke yeah
maybe yeah damn yeah that guy really did
it man yeah he really went for it he
believed in something
he didn't like gays man he loved him
he loved them
yeah but it was interesting he didn't
want people to leave him that's why he
did it so they'd stay forever
you know outside the box thinking that's
we need more of in this country Jeffrey
Dahmer hero spelled his name with an H
you know who would have thought H in the
middle of that who would have thought
eat
that guy [__] outside the bombers
wouldn't that be crazy that would be
great oh dumbers and it'd be like Burger
shaped like fingers and stuff like you
know a lot of chicken fingers a lot of
chicken fingers yeah chicken is just
wink the chicken's winking we're going
80s boy come and get it we're going to
Hades
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one